Netflix's latest horror hit is thrilling
viewers even as it challenges the
audience to figure out what the heck is
actually happening from blades to bugs
and that wild final act here's our
breakdown of what it all means in the
ending of the perfection spoilers ahead
the perfection story is told in
fragments presented out of order that
first becomes clear when we see
Charlotte and Lizzie's trip through
China first through Lizzy's eyes drugged
and without context and then from
Charlotte's perspective telling the
story this way was a risky move for
director Richard Shepherd and company
but non-traditional story structure has
paid off in the past for movies like
Reservoir Dogs and Eternal Sunshine of
the spotless mind films for which
planting uncertainty in the audience
leads to a satisfying payoff and makes
trying to guess what's going on part of
the fun the perfection adds to this by
attaching the uncertainty to what should
be a pretty simple question in a horror
picture who is the monster here it's
only as the story nears its violent
climax that we truly understand that the
real monster is Anton head of the
back-off Academy the events of the
perfection may feature a ton of twists
and narrative shifts but the action and
horror is all part of the journey to the
end a decade after leaving back off
Academy
Charlotte is still trying to deal with
the damage done to her at the school
from the start we get the impression
that this woman has unresolved possibly
dangerous mental issues the tension
mounts as she heads to Shanghai to meet
her former teacher Anton there Charlotte
falls back into the good graces of the
school staff and get seduced by the new
star pupil Lizzy the two decide to take
a trip into the Chinese countryside
together and stuff starts to get
prescription-strength weird on the trip
Charlotte drugs Lizzy with medication
she took from her mother inducing a
stomach flu and hallucinations the tour
kicked off their bus in the middle of
nowhere and Charlotte convinces a
delusional Lizzy that her hand is full
of bugs prompting Lizzy to go 127 hours
on herself with a cleaver
[Music]
we learned towards the very end of the
film that after Lizzy wakes up Charlotte
is still with her she tells Lizzy that
this was the only way to free her from
the Academy's brainwashing and that
they'll turn their backs on her now that
she's no longer useful to them
Charlotte returns home and Lizzy tries
to go back to back off
although Anton lets Lizzy stay it back
off for a while he eventually kicks her
out just like Charlotte predicted bitter
and lost Lizzy proceeds to break into
Charlotte's house intent on killing her
then Lizzy bring Charlotte back to the
back off Academy as a prisoner she's
chained up and forced to play for the
staff and misses one note as the faculty
closes in on her though they start
falling to the floor because Lizzy has
drugged their drinks through the final
flashback we returned to Charlotte's
house and see Lizzy finally
acknowledging that Charlotte was right
she's been brainwashed and they both
agree that the creep said back off need
to be stopped in the final shots in the
movie we see Charlotte and Lizzy playing
a single cello together each with one
arm
Anton meanwhile is dismembered blinded
and castrated hooked up to a feeding
tube being forced to listen it's a
bizarre yet emotional moment for both
the audience and for Lizzie and
Charlotte the room they're in the chapel
had always been a sacred place for Anton
it's where he dreamed of hearing
perfection veteran students were brought
in there to play a perfect piece only to
be punished when they missed a note we
don't make mistakes here when we
represent the Academy with all his limbs
gone and his eyes and mouth sewn shut
Anton is essentially locked in a mental
prison where he's forced to listen to
Charlotte and Lizzy play forever
what if they miss a note who cares
they're playing for themselves now and
Anton has no choice but to endure it it
probably goes without saying that this
movie is rooted deeply in recent social
phenomena like the times up in me two
movements and it brings a level of
fictionalized catharsis in the form of a
gruesome conclusion this is a
long-running tradition in the horror
genre a character or force representing
a real-world fear is brought down by the
forces of good alien famously used it
Xenomorphs as an allegory for sexual
violence and get out pretty brilliantly
turned racism and gentrification into
Frankenstein monstrosity in the same way
the perfection tackles institutionalized
abuse gas lighting and toxic misuse of
power when Charlotte and Lizzie forces
severely DeLand Anton to listen to them
play they're not just reclaiming their
power they're asserting their self-worth
over an abusive power structure that
spent years objectifying them if you saw
the trailer for the perfection you were
probably pretty intrigued you were also
probably wildly thrown off when you
watch the actual movie the trailer for
the perfection made it out to be
something that was decidedly not a bug
infestation freakout picture it made
heavy use of the scene when stranded on
the side of the road
Lizzie screams at Charlotte about the
bugs crawling inside of her arm beyond
that were not given much information as
to what the film is about
besides being informed that Charlotte is
the kind of person who's always prepared
in case a meat cleaver might come in
wait for it handy Netflix was pretty
cautious about not giving anything away
in the trailer and it makes sense the
movies emotional gravity is predicated
on the audience having as little
information as possible and in a messed
up sorta way it's kind of fitting that a
movie based on surprising twists was
marketed through yet another twist with
everything happening on screen the
audience could pretty easily overlook
some of the musical cues in the
perfection the thing is some of that
music is pretty important for one thing
Anton is pretty consistently associated
with Mozart's Requiem in D minor it's a
bombastic foreboding series of pieces
the most dramatic of which DCI plays
when Anton approaches Lizzy in the
driveway unaware that he's about to be
horribly dismembered as a result of his
own misdeeds aside from the song's
lyrics about judgment and reckoning you
could go even deeper with this choice of
music the story goes that Mozart told
his wife that he was writing the mass
for his own funeral when he died before
completing the Requiem he left the
completion of the composition to one of
his former assistants intentional or not
it's a fitting song to play as Anton
arrives at his eventual doom in a school
which will soon be controlled by his own
former students check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite films
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]